Speaker 1: Today.
It's great to be joined by Democratic Congressman
Adam Schiff, who is a progressive leader in
Congress representing California's 30th District.
He is running for Senate, hoping to build
an economy that works for everyone and safeguard
our democracy, protect the planet, things
which really should not be controversial at
this point in time.
Congressman, great to have you on.
Listen, let me start with what I know is on
the forefront of many of my viewers minds,
which is, is anybody getting indicted at any
point?
You know, we've been going through this thing
for years and we've been talking about the
former president and associates and others.
Where are you on this issue at this point
of what you expect to see?
Speaker 2: Yeah, you know, I have been fairly
conservative in my expectations, mainly because
I don't want to get my hopes up, but also
because the Justice Department has been so
slow to move for so long.
They moved with alacrity when it came to the
people breaking into the Capitol on January
six and assaulting police officers.
But it took them a very long time to investigate
the multiple efforts, multiple lines of effort
to overturn the election.
The president's call with the Georgia secretary
of state, for example, but also his role in
the incitement of that attack, the higher
ups in that plot that culminated on January
6th.
You know, we were way out ahead of them in
the investigation, which is very unusual for
Congress, as cumbersome as it is to be ahead
of the Justice Department.
Yeah, I do think the appointment of a special
counsel was a positive sign because he seems
to be, you know, not not cautious like the
attorney general and leaning into the investigation
finally.
I also am very impressed with what we see
out of Fulton County, Georgia.
In many respects, I'm more optimistic about
the prosecutor, Fulton County, than I am about
the Justice Department.
But I think prudently we should expect that
there's no prosecutor who will rescue the
country from this danger that we may just
very well have to defeat it at the polls again.
But I will be happily proven wrong by either
prosecutor or the Manhattan D.A., which I
think is probably the the least likely candidate
to move forward, but nonetheless, more exposure
of the president.
Speaker 1: So over the weekend, at a particularly
deranged edition of CPAC, Donald Trump held
sort of like an impromptu press conference
and was asked some version of the question,
If you are indicted, however many times, will
that interfere with your presidential run?
And he said no.
And the entire atmosphere at CPAC, I don't
know how much you saw, but one of the trends
is that the biggest applause lines are either
homophobic or more recently transphobic stuff.
This really seems to get the modern right
excited.
Maybe part of it is because there's a sort
of lack of policy outside of this sort of
rhetoric.
How concerned are you about the degree to
which the transgender community now seems
to be the primary target of the MAGA movement?
Speaker 2: I'm deeply concerned about it.
I'm a vice chair of the Equality Caucus.
So this is an issue I've been very focused
on, on behalf of my constituents.
And you're right, just a couple of weeks ago,
Donald Trump did a video from Mar a Lago.
The whole purpose of which was to demonize
the trans community, basically to, I guess,
show his GOP Trump MAGA base that he's even
worse on those issues than Ron DeSantis.
And this is the kind of primary that's going
on in the GOP, which is who can most dehumanize
one of the most vulnerable populations in
the country, one that has a very high, tragic
and very high suicide rate, as well as being
the victim of a lot of violence directed at
the community by others.
So I'm deeply concerned about it.
This is what autocrats and would be autocrats
do.
They look to the most vulnerable and try to
dehumanize them.
And it also, I think, is a signal of, you
know, other rights they want to take away
from Americans they've taken away or tried
to reproductive freedom through this multi-decade
effort at the Supreme Court.
And they may target other rights and freedoms
of other Americans, particularly vulnerable
ones.
Speaker 1: You know, Senator Bernie Sanders
recently in an interview, I don't remember
which one had a sort of very interesting,
candid moment where he said, listen, you know,
based on how long he's been doing this and
his age, am I going to get Medicare for all
passed?
No.
But am I maybe going to continue doing things
that get more people health care?
Am I going to make incremental steps, sort
of, in a sense, channeling the idea of Ted
Kennedy, of incrementalism and taking steps
forward as you now are running for Senate?
And it's an interesting race, which we will
talk about.
How do you balance the.
Idea of what you would do if it were simply
up to you.
And the reality of partizan gridlock needing
60 votes in the Senate to accomplish so many
different things, the reality that the moneyed
rate is still extraordinarily effective at
using fundraising and lobbying to prevent
progress from being made.
How do you balance what you would do if it
was just up to you and the reality of what
can be accomplished in a six year term?
Speaker 2: Well, I also support Medicare for
All, but I'm a big believer that you make
progress where you can make progress.
And, you know, at the end of the day, you
can't be progressive if you're not willing
to make progress.
I'm enormously proud of what we did in the
Affordable Care Act, which brought health
care to tens of millions of people that didn't
have it otherwise.
I do think and I was a vocal advocate at the
time, it was a huge missed opportunity not
to pass the public option when we passed the
Affordable Care Act.
That would have been, I think, the most substantial
downward driver of cost of anything we were
doing at the time and would have forced not
only more reasonable costs for health care,
but that would have given us a model, a medicare
for all model to build on.
So that was a terrible missed opportunity
nonetheless.
But I have not passed the Affordable Care
Act because we didn't do that.
Now, I'm glad I supported the final product,
even if it wasn't exactly what I wanted, because
it has done so much good.
And I think we are moving inexorably towards
universal care.
We just need to keep the fire lit, keep pushing
to get there quicker.
And I'm still hopeful we will do it in Bernie
Sanders lifetime.
A little on my own.
And but I don't think we let the enemy be
the or the good be the enemy of the the perfect
be the enemy of the good.
Excuse me.
Speaker 1: When it comes to speaking of age,
you there's this interesting dynamic that's
developed over in the Republican presidential
primary where Nikki Haley announced that she's
running.
And when she's been asked numerous times,
why would someone vote for you instead of
Trump?
Sometimes she's visibly confused, and when
she's able to put together an answer, it's
usually about identity.
Despite claiming to be against identity politics,
she's put together.
Well, I'm younger, I'm a woman, and I'm a
of a minority background of Indian background.
In your Senate race, the retiring the outgoing
senator Dianne Feinstein, is around 90 years
old.
The you're running early sixties.
Katie Porter's 49.
Barbara Lee, 76 years old.
How important to you do you think this idea
of Democrats needing a new generation in power,
how important do you think that is?
Speaker 2: You know, I think it really depends
entirely on the person.
You know, so many young people are enthusiastic
supporters of Bernie Sanders, not because
of his age, but because a lot of his ideas
are new and his ideas appeal to young people.
That, to me, I think, is more important than
what the age of the person is.
That is, what are they advocating?
What's their ability to get things done?
And so people often make that synonymous with
age, but it's not always the case.
And I think, you know, Joe Biden has been
able to achieve great things for the country,
including one of the most aggressive attacks
on climate change in our history.
You might not expect that from a president
of his age, but nonetheless, you know, he
has been, I think, very effective and very
progressive.
At the same time, voters are going to consider
these factors.
Voters are going to look at age, they're going
to look at gender, they're going to look at
race.
They should look at all of these things.
They're also going to look at who can deliver
for California, who is going to get things
done, who's going to improve the quality of
my life, who's going to help make sure I can
live in a in a good neighborhood with good
public schools that my kids will be able to
afford.
Higher education won't be saddled with that.
Who is going to make sure we can drink the
water and breathe the air?
At the end of the day, they're looking for
people who will deliver for California, and
I think they will look for that regardless
of age.
I think they will look at who's got the track
record of getting things done.
Speaker 1: When it comes to something like
tax policy to pick something extremely both
substantive and and concrete.
There's the very general idea of the rich
should pay more.
On the right, you have ideas from flat taxes
to cutting taxes for the rich, all sorts of
different ideas.
Right now we have a system where the highest
tax bracket federally, 37%, around half a
million dollars in income.
I know that's not exact.
I don't remember if it's 460 or 520 this year
or exactly where it is in your ideal tax program.
How much higher than 37 do you go, if at all?
And where would those higher tax brackets
start?
And one of the things I find is whenever I
ask elected officials this, rarely do I get
numbers as answers.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, and I don't want to
disappoint you don't have a target number
either.
Okay.
But, you know, a big part of why I'm running
is to make the economy work for everyone in
a way that is just not working right now.
And a big chunk of that is the tax code.
When I was a kid, my father was a salesman.
He made $18,000 a year.
He bought a house for our family here.
My mother, that cost $18,000.
You can't do that now.
And not all of it is.
You know, the the as my Republican colleagues
would like to believe, the product of some
kind of impersonal market forces or Adam Smith's
invisible hand.
A lot of the reason why the economy isn't
working is the product of a very invisible
hand of a very powerful lobbyist or a very
powerful corporate interest in terms of the
tax code when we more than doubled, for example,
the child tax credit, yeah, that lifted 40%
of the kids out of poverty.
And when that was allowed to lapse, millions
fell back into poverty.
That was a policy choice we made, and it's
a terrible policy choice.
So I would begin in terms of reforming the
tax code, more than doubling the child tax
credit, I would begin by providing very generous
tax subsidies for people trying to for child
care so we have accessible, affordable child
care.
So more women in particular, but men, too,
can enter the job force because they can afford
quality child care.
I would do away with how we treat the carried
interest of hedge fund managers who get a
enormous tax break.
They're some of the wealthiest people in the
country.
Yeah, that break not because it makes sense,
it doesn't, but because they have very powerful
interests lobbying for them.
So a lot of these changes would make the tax
code far more progressive.
In addition to our we treat the top, top line
rate payers.
Speaker 1: Would you like to see a top rate
that is higher than 37%?
Speaker 2: I'm certainly open to that so that
we have a tax code that is more progressive.
I just don't know that I can give you the
ideal number.
Yeah, but I think and going beyond the tax
code, there are innumerable ways that we can
make the economy work better for people where
we can incentivize the construction of more
housing that's affordable, where we can ease
the, you know, the debt that students are
forced to live under, all of which I would
put under the category of making the economy
work for people again.
Speaker 1: Let's talk about the cost of college
a little bit since you mentioned that.
So I'm trying to figure out.
So my daughter is eight months old.
I started the 529.
Right.
I'm pretending as though the world is normal
and it's going to be the same in 18 years
when it comes time for her to have the opportunity
to go to college.
But I'm also doing the math, and I know that
for her to go to the same school that I or
my girlfriend went to, if costs keep going
up at the same rate that they have been over
the last 20 years, it'll be about $205,000
per year for tuition when she is 18.
It sounds like that can't possibly happen
like that.
Something has to break in the next 17 and
a half years or not, Right.
I mean, if if student lending continues to
stay the way it is and people can just get
loans, I mean, it just the numbers don't seem
to make any sense.
Speaker 2: They don't make any sense.
And it's a tragedy the way we've funded higher
education essentially on the back of students.
I can relate a bit.
When I graduated from graduate school, my
loans were at nine, 12 and 14% interest and
my my loan payments were higher than my rent
for about the next ten years.
Right.
I went into the law where I could afford to
pay them off, which most people don't have
that luxury and it obviously circumscribed
what they could do with their careers, where
they can follow their passion.
It's just a terrible way to fund education.
And I do think we need a complete restructuring
so that we don't, you know, put on the backs
of students the obligation to to pay for higher
education this way.
It is unsustainable.
And and and sadly, this should have been done
years ago so that the people that have the
debt now didn't have to incur it.
And we cannot have a situation where your
kids are going to have to pay 200 K a year.
That's just going to mean higher ed is only
available to the wealthiest Americans.
So we need to change how we fund it.
We need to change the whole structure of it.
We ought to, I think, begin by forgiving student
debt.
And we certainly shouldn't be forcing students
to pay the government and.
First on their student loans.
We shouldn't be the federal government shouldn't
be earning any kind of revenue or profit from
that.
Speaker 1: Couple other things in the in the
limited time we have from a political strategy
perspective, I'm curious, you know, there's
this discussion now about the Republican primary
for 24 and what it will mean in a trickle
down sense, including for races like yours
and in the House of Representatives and others.
There is one feeling that if someone like
Ron DeSantis were to run, that he would be,
if he became the president, significantly
more dangerous than Donald Trump, and that
he is more committed, less distractible and
potentially more effective at doing really
dangerous authoritarian things.
And so in some sense, the country would be
better off with Donald Trump as the nominee
because it would he would not only be more
beatable if he was president, he would accomplish
fewer dangerous things.
And when it comes to races like yours, his
presence on the ticket may inspire more turnout
and help progressives and Democrats across
the country.
Do you have a view on the strategic aspect
of what happens in that Republican primary?
Speaker 2: I do.
And I would put myself squarely, I guess,
in the opposite camp.
I know many Democrats feel like they would
like, even aside from who became president,
they would like Trump as the nominee because
they believe he would be easier to beat.
Yes, he might be easier to beat than Ron DeSantis.
But the danger of his presidency of a second
president to me is such a horrible prospect
that I don't even endure the possibility.
No, not that I have any say in who becomes
the Republican nominee, but I would rather
have the tougher person to beat than the even
the prospect that Donald Trump could be successful
in a general election.
I do think that he is, although he's not as
bright as the Santos, he is a uniquely talented
grifter.
Yes.
Uniquely dangerous and shrewd divider of peoples.
And so I think he would just tear the country
apart to Santos would be a different kind
of horror show.
But but to me, Trump learned from the first
four years.
And, you know, he started out with a couple
of people of stature like Secretary Mattis
and consecutively got rid of anyone who had
any independent gravitas to stand up to him.
Right.
And and put in place increasingly sycophantic
people.
He would start out with the worst of the worst
if he got another term.
And and one thing we did see with him is that
each abuse of presidential power was followed
by an even worse one, culminating in insurrection.
So to me, anything is preferable to that.
Speaker 1: When he started saying, Your head
is like a watermelon.
Were you hoping he would pick a different
fruit or vegetable?
Although watermelon is a great it's delicious.
But what's your reaction to that?
Speaker 2: Well, my reaction was, you know,
he went from calling me a pencil neck to a
watermelon head.
And let me just say a watermelon head on a
pencil neck is a pretty tough balance.
Speaker 1: As it is.
Speaker 2: But my my predominant thought on
the on the various nicknames was, you know,
I thought he was better at it than that.
The whole, you know, cardinal rule of nicknames
is you pick one and you stick to it.
Yes.
And he's had about eight of them for me over
the years.
And and so I don't think they've been as effective
as they could be if he just stuck to one.
Speaker 1: It is interesting that he always
puts a caveat when he mentions you that you're
a bright guy.
I don't.
Do you have any insight as to why he kind
of mentions that every single time?
Speaker 2: You know, it is it is interesting.
When I met him in the Oval Office during the
whole Devin Nunes midnight run thing.
Yeah, he came out from behind the Resolute
desk, where I have to say, he looked it looked
like the cover of Mad magazine to me.
It definitely did not belong in that picture.
He comes out from behind the desk.
The first thing he does when he shakes my
hand and says, you know, you do a really good
job.
Presumably he means on TV.
Oh, that.
That I understood.
Because that's what he that's what impresses
him how you do on TV.
But I tell you, it was pretty awkward because
when somebody says something like that to
you, you know, you do a really good job.
The first human impulses to want to say, well,
so do you.
But there was no way I could bring myself
to saying that.
So it was quite an awkward pause after that
comment.
Speaker 1: That's a thank you, sir moment
as And it would become one of his sir anecdotes
that he's known for.
Democratic Congressman Adam Schiff is running
in California for the Senate seat being vacated
by longtime Senator Dianne Feinstein.
I know you're busy.
I really appreciate your time and your insights
today.
Speaker 2: Great to be with you.
Thanks for having me on.